would the senator modify his request  to include a unanimous consent request  that the senate to include unanimous  consent  that the senate proceed to the immediate  consideration of h.r 9051  a bill received from the house to  increase recovery rebate amounts to two  thousand dollars per individual  that the bill be read a third time and  passed  the motion to reconsider be considered  made and laid upon  the table with no intervening action or  debate  is there objection to the modification  object  objection is heard is there objection to  the original request  the senator from vermont thank you for  reserving  reserving the right to object  we should all be very very clear  the working class of this country today  faces more economic desperation  than at any time since the great  depression of the nineteen thirties  and working families need help  now not next year  but right now last night  the house of representatives